do you think that women become more or
less hypergamous post their sexual
Marcus Peak there's some VP Peak do you
think they can um well hypergamy is
multifaceted
um like younger women younger women will
get with a guy that's a hot dude but has
a plan over a long-term basis okay like
they'll like they'll Overlook the lack
of financial resources for like a 22
year old guy but if you're a 40 or 50
year old guy and you have a plan and
you're still hot but you don't have
anything going on like you have nothing
to show for yourself women don't have a
lot of interest in guys like that
because by then they've started to
acquire a lot more in the way of
resources they may have been divorced
and taken half of a guy's assets maybe
they're a corporate gal and they've
climbed the corporate ladder and making
100 150 200 000 a year so they're doing
well they have their own stuff
um so hypergamia is is there's basically
two sides to it there's the alpha [__]
side also known as Alpha seed and
there's the beta Buck side so
and that changes you know throughout the
cycle of the month right like women when
women are ovulating that's when they
want the alpha [__] that's that's when
they want the dominant C that's when
they want the tall guy with the muscles
narrow waist broad shoulders chisel jaw
deep voice high testosterone cues
Believe It or Not women can smell high
testosterone they've done tests on this
where they'll have guys like sleep and
like you know Cotton shirts and they'll
have women smell the shirts uh like 36
hours later and the guy with the high
serum blood testosterone she can smell
that guy right like it is it is
ridiculous how women made select
um you know when you kind of get into it
you see the code in The Matrix for what
it is but yeah you know so it happens
when they're ovulating like the vast
majority of women cheating in long-term
relationships and marriages happen when
they're ovulating so if you're a guy in
a marriage or a long-term relationship
and you should be checking sorry
tracking your woman's cycle by the way
um and if she is ovulating and if you
see her getting dressed up and wanting
to go out with her girlfriends on a
frequent basis when she's on ovulating
lipstick high heels short skirts lots of
skin exposed bright red lipstick the big
hoopty hoop earrings that's because
she's out marketing herself and she's
marketing herself when she's in a
position to get pregnant she's not going
to tell you that but that's what she's
doing that's what her nature is doing
she wants to show herself off and that
is also happens to coincidentally be the
time when most women cheat on their men
is when they go out again for the girls
weekends for the girls night out
whatever if they're in a long-term
relationship when they're ovulated they
don't do it when they're on their period
they don't do it when they're that's
part of their cycle that's when they
want beta bucks it's when they want
Comfort that's when they want the
blankie and curl up and watch Netflix
with you they won't go out with their
girls then that's that's when they want
to hang out with you and be all warm and
cuddly and snuggly so
um so it changes month a month it
changes in different areas of their life
women generally in their 20s are more in
their party years they like to
experience guys they look for the high
testosterone Q alpha males they want
very little to do with the beta
providers they just want to they just
want to have fun you know like Cyndi
Lauper says right but when they start
hitting close to 30 and they get to
their Epiphany phase and they start
looking around and they're seeing all
their girlfriends getting married and
having kids they're siblings that's when
they want to get right with God and just
say you know like I need to find a guy
and quite often that's when they usually
just find a guy that's good enough
because all the high value alpha males
that they spent their 20s banging don't
want anything to do with them because
now they have a notch count racked up
and they're 30 35 and they want a date
20 23 year olds they don't want anything
to do with a girl that's been run
through you know by a bunch of guys so
that's why a lot of women end up
marrying beta males right because
they're more compliant they're more
agreeable
um you know they'll do exactly what they
want alpha males don't comply right like
if she says well I want to move my mom
in from such and such country and we
need to renovate the kitchen and we have
to move to this city a beta male will
say yeah okay but an alpha male will
lead the frame and say you know this is
the way things are going to be so
women's women's needs and desires change
over time that's why
um
that's why the notion of paternity fraud
you know still exists today where like
when a woman's pregnant she has 100
assurance that it's her kid 100 there's
no question in her mind she's pregnant
she's carrying it that's her kid okay
but guys don't have Assurance that's why
men get jealous of their women when
they're exposed to getting banged by
other guys women on the other hand
they're more concerned with him uh
giving up resources and attention to
another woman because if they lose that
if they get pregnant then that's a high
risk factor for them right so men and
women are completely different in so
many areas of their lives at different
parts of their lives
um it's a very complex equation but when
you start to understand today again you
know once you unplug and you see the
code in The Matrix and you understand
everything that's going on it's very
very easy for a guy to navigate it
properly
so coming back then to the original
question is like I I think you answered
it is you know once they reach that sort
of epiphany stage you know even if
they're still a hot sort of 30 year old
or whatever you know they
I think they are
less likely to be
as hypergamous as they were when they
were younger because well they still had
the gifts in the sense that that their
that their mindset has shifted from the
sexy hot guy from the phone camera party
and
Ibiza or Cancun or whatever like it
shifts from that guy more to the guy
like you know what he's he's just tall
enough for me he looks just masculine
enough his job is good enough right
um
I'll have his kids but he's but he's got
his money sorted for them the comfort of
uh protecting and providing is more
important at that time when they're
looking at kids and a lot of the times
women cut guys too right like they'll
like they'll go and get Knocked Up by
the hot guy but then they'll have the
beta male provide for that child
um it's it's you know I went through a
lot of data trying to find accurate
information on the cuckolding rate today
when it comes to
um guys being duped and you know
thinking that the kid is theirs but it's
not and it's very very difficult because
um cucking a guy
relies on deception and women aren't
going to be honest about lying to the
guy that's raising the kid about whether
or not he's a kid so you're never going
to get an honest answer one of the
studies that I found that I thought was
fascinating was
um there was a school in the UK that was
doing like a family tree sort of
experiment
um I'm going to butcher this because it
was about four years ago I was you know
going through the data but it's all in
my book
um and they ended up sending the kids
home and when they all came back with
the information that the school was
looking for to do the family tree to
identify you know uh maternity and
paternity and grandfathers you know on
both sides and grandmothers and all that
sort of stuff they soon realized about
30 percent of the children in the
classroom weren't with their biological
father they were they were with a man
that thought was a biological father but
wasn't so they had to stop doing this
[__] experiment because it was
ruining households 30 percent 30 percent
now I don't know that 30 is common
throughout Society I mean it seems like
somewhere between 10 and 15 would be
more realistic but maybe it was a
anomaly because of the Town
um you know like there's certain places
in the UK where women are are pretty
much like big time hoes right you know
if you traveled there
um so it so it could have been like that
but I don't think that 30 is common
throughout Society it seems like
somewhere between 10 and 15 would be a a
lot more normalized but a lot of guys
that are out there today raising
children they're not the biological
father and they just don't know it
I mean that would probably be more in
the west right
yeah I'd I'd kind of I mean you know
because in most other countries you know
throughout the world men have authority
and responsibility in the household yeah
so they don't let their girlfriends or
wives run around doing things like they
do in the west being highly promiscuous
right I really hope you guys enjoyed
that clip if you want to watch the full
length podcast you can find that over
here that clips from if you're new to
the channel make sure you hit subscribe
over here and pin down below in the top
comment you'll find a bunch of useful
links to my website my supplement line
books and a bunch of other stuff have an
amazing day peace out